have you heard the new term spore no
sexual yeah spore no sexuals are the new
metrosexuals mark Simpson who's the
journalist who coined the term
metrosexual and these were these guys
had started probably about ten years ago
who cared what they looked like they
wore clothes that were a little tighter
kind of a little gayer but they weren't
gay they were straight guys it seems to
look a little gayer put you a put a
little more product in their hair that
kind of thing I'm feeling good about my
hair today they look great but now he's
now talking abouts porno sexuals and
this is this new group of men who are
who are hyper sexual and body obsessed
we've got an explanation of the Spore no
sexual with their painstakingly pumped
and chiseled bodies muscle enhancing
tattoos piercings adorable beards and
plunging necklines it's eye-catching ly
clear that the second generation
metrosexuality is less about clothes
than it was for the first their own
bodies more than clobber and product
have become their ultimate accessories
fashioning them at the gym into a hot
commodity one that they share and
compare in an online marketplace so the
online marketplace that he's talking
about of course is social media that
people are taking the you know selfies
everywhere at the gym perfect bodies
tattooed and tight haircuts blah blah
blah is this the the is the gay agenda
is it working are they turning all of
the straight people gay is that what
happening here yes and you know the
children the child this is fantastic I
mean I think that first of all it's a
great definition terrible name it sounds
like you have some sort of an ASP or
induced STD yeah but god bless
Sporto sexual the first thing I thought
I mean you know my golden bear thing
Dorothy Zbornak so I thought it was
someone that was obsessed with Bea
Arthur perhaps which is I can't live in
a world that wonderful there is no
utopia worth everywhere a sport or
sexual everyone obsessed would be Arthur
but I mean this is absolutely accurate
is it not I mean hit the word hipster is
so played out and I don't even think
that that definition really means
anything anymore I think it's the sport
of sexual you got the beard you got the
plunging neckline
yeah and
all your glamour muscles exactly where
you want them you probably can't
actually lift something heavy but you
look great right so this is accurate
right right well this reminds me of I
live in West Hollywood and all these
guys that have huge muscles and they
probably couldn't throw a ball four feet
away because it's all about the visual
component do you do you like these kind
of guys excuse to not wear clothes
anymore no wants to wear clothes like
you have James Franco just holding this
junk and I see your pubes on Instagram I
saw something that the day where now you
know your little speedo you used to wear
a speedo now it's like one faster it's
just like a ball it's like fat yeah just
goes over one side like people just know
one of our clothes because they want to
show off their abs and their arms and
their nipples in there whatever I love
it I think it's hilarious
I didn't think I'm being that could go
down to your ankle right like what is it
now she's like a robe like what is it I
love it yeah do you think there's some
element of it that men lose a little
something something that women love
about men maybe when they are so into
themselves you know men are always
complaining every sitcom ever is about
the man complaining the white it scared
about too much her hair and her brother
and now men are doing it yeah and then
the other complaint is well I don't want
to date a guy that takes longer to get
ready than I do right and I mean that
for me that's impossible because I mean
clearly this took no more than I find
with that that's that's not how
uncomfortable but I think that I think
there that you're both right I think
it's fun I candy it's fun to look at
it's fun to make fun of it's fun to talk
about it's fun to see pictures of but in
general do I feel like I'm gonna connect
to somebody who is just like all oiled
up probably not my guy but I love the
conversation yeah what do you think
what's the face after this if it started
you had regular guys then you had the
metrosexuals now we got this porno
section I mean is it just everyone's
important next is that where we're going
is that it does that over my $30,000
Starbuzz scholarship - yeah okay this
rolled into this for no way that's right
no I think what it does is just breeds
more narcissism and the Instagram the
selfie the I see that everything is an e
it just breathes I just it's all about
me and me
me look at my hands it's just over the
top it's over the top
[Music]